>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Mark Dimunation: Welcome
everybody to Thursday at 3:00
and the Rare Book and
Special Collections Division,
part of the Rare Book Forum.
Some of you are familiar faces
but leave it to Peter to draw
in a whole new crowd as well.
It shouldn't surprise any of
you that you know, Peter Zilahy;
he's going to be speaking
about time.
I met Peter when he first arrived
as a Kluge Scholar two years ago?
Yes. At that time I was working in
the reading room and at the desk
in the reference section, which is a
grand theater seat for the division
but also you're kind
of a prime target.
So, Peter came by and
as often as those of you
who know Peter will know a short
conversation with Peter turns
into endless story after story
and it became kind of this moment
that I would look forward to when
he would walk in the reading room.
We would go over everything from
panslovic backgrounds to any number
of issues with books to his current
work; so it's been a real pleasure
to have him associated with
the division all these years.
Today he's going to be speaking
on in essence perception
or how we relay our perception
of time and timelessness.
I won't say more because
he, as you know,
if you know him will have a very
unique take on the subject matter;
so please welcome Peter,
and it's all yours.
[ Applause ]
>> Peter Zilahy: Mark thank you
very much for the introduction.
It's strange how memory works
because I remember
our first encounter.
You were the one who was telling
the stories, endless stories.
So the title is Time
and Timelessness,
everything you always wanted to
know about time, but you were afraid
to ask, the brackets naturally
refer to the Q & A at the end.
So, because of the
camera I will mostly read
because I wouldn't
like to make a mistake.
So my last talk at the Library of
Congress was on visual thinking
with lots of images and visual aids.
So, this time I decided to
keep it more personal due
to the subject matter, that
is time and timelessness,
and also because of
furniture in this room.
Look at that amazing piece
there, if you are getting bored,
just admire it and it can pass your
time in perfect visual harmony.
If you don't see that table at
the end, you should really check
that out that's an
amazing collector's item.
And so I should call
this work in progress,
but that would already mean
taking a side in the debate
that is literally as old as time.
So there's another lecture
at 4:00 at the Kluge Center,
so no hard feelings for
those who will have to go.
I just wanted to inform
the rest of the people
that if anybody leaves the
room before the fat lady sings,
it's not because she's bombing.
As you can see Thursday's are
popular for lectures and talks,
and Thursday are also
popular in literature.
There are novels whose plots
take place in a single day.
Mrs. Dalloway takes place
on a Wednesday in June 1923,
perhaps because Thursday had already
been taken by James Joyce's Ulysses,
also in June exactly 113 years ago.
The books that you can
see on the table there
and perhaps holding your hands
later were written by me.
And as you will see are full of
images as opposed to my lecture.
They play the theme of
childhood and dictatorship.
One of them looks like a
children's dictionary and it's
about among other things,
a childhood span behind
the Iron Curtain.
The idea was that everybody
was treated like children
by the regime, not just me.
But my parents and teachers as well,
so a children's dictionary seemed
to be the ideal form
to write about the era.
I'll give you a short example.
"Bath time was during the news.
Every now and then mother would
look in to see if I was all right.
Dad was watching TV
in the living room.
To protect me from the lies
they had to know the details.
I could hear mother sighing,
what a mess I was making
on flooding the apartment.
I dived down.
Under the water I heard a voice
telling me what had happened
in the world that day.
A landslide killed 150 people in
Bangladesh, a revolution broke
out in West Africa,
a new kindergarten
and Olympic swimming
pool were opened,
and MTK beat Ferencvaros two to one.
I had no idea who was
sending the messages or why,
but clearly they had plans for me
because they also told me what
the weather was going to be like.
The following day I could
distinguish several voices
in the tub which pointed
towards an organization.
This manner of communication
seemed logical.
I couldn't send them messages
because you can't talk under water,
and they could only get in
touch with me without my parents
and teachers knowing
during my bath time.
I didn't understand why it was
important for the organization
that I should have detailed
information on the latest war games
in Poland, or which Transdanubian
towns were being granted city
status, but I knew that
if I paid attention sooner
or later I'd be given a sign.
My life gained a deeper
meaning under water
when one Sunday mother
was washing my hair
and unsuspecting she pushed
my head into the water;
a pleasant female voice
whispered in my ear
that the harvest had
been flattened by hail.
I knew immediately
what was expected of me
and to be honest I
had no objections.
To make a big mess.
From that day on I
sabotaged the development
of our people's democracy
like a busy honeybee.
Earthquake, power failures and
gas explosions marked my way.
I would figure out the location of
military objectives on the basis
of intelligence I received
in the bath tub.
When a factory or a power plant was
inaugurated I would be there doing
what I had to do.
Comecon fiddled at repairs behind
the Iron Curtain, little suspecting
that some, that a stone was being
thrown inside the glass house."
In the opening of Either
or, Kierkegaard,
the Danish Philosopher
talks about the brazen bull
which is both an instrument
of torture and music.
Filary is the tyrant of
a Greek city/state more
than 2,000 years ago had this
device for his pleasures.
The bronze bull was
heated from below
and the victim was slowly
roasted while his screams came
through as music with
the help of various pipe
and some clever engineering.
This actually happened.
There are no recordings
of the musical quality
because as you know recording
devices are rather modern form
of torture and the
brazen bull is ancient.
What is a poet Kierkegaard
asks, an unhappy person
who conceals profound anguish in his
heart with whose lips are so foreign
that his cries sound
like beautiful music.
And the crowd goes, "Sing again,
me and you suffering
torture your soul".
Music and torture was never far
from each other as well illustrated
by the British Heavy Metal
band Iron Maiden that was named
after a torture device
of similar sorts.
Only that device never actually
existed, but was completely made up.
They do look amazing, so you
can still find Iron Maiden
in torture museums around the
world, if that's where you hang out.
Fictional torture device sounds
like a collection of bad poetry
or a novel that is literally
crime scene, we've all been there.
By the way bad poetry
causes dementia.
Even if you're not
listening just sitting nearby,
it's like secondary smoke
and you get lung cancer.
Just Google it.
Anyway this is a perfect place to
make a statement, be it philosophy,
literature or science there are
only good books and bad books.
Good books connect the world;
bad books make money
and/or cause dementia.
Play to [Inaudible] Kierkegaard
and Nietzsche wrote some
great literary works.
Even Wittgenstein had
some amazing one liners.
At the same time a lot
of good literature turned
out to contain great philosophical
or scientific insights.
Those [Inaudible] not only
influenced Kafka a great deal
but Einstein as well.
You must look at the bigger picture,
which is also why I'm not
showing small images this time.
Coherence plays back
in the long run.
So, to be fair Kierkegaard writes
that he would rather be a
swineherd understood by his pigs
than a poet misunderstood by people.
So if you are a poet you just need
to find the place where your screams
in pain are appreciated as
beautiful music or start a blog.
This - that's enough
of my go to humor.
Dictatorship have great audiences,
and not just because
people cannot leave but also
because everything
has a double meaning.
To read between the
lines is key to survival
but also a creative process
that's much more entertaining
for an informed crowd than
any form of [Inaudible].
Your expectations define
the reading.
Sometimes you cannot see the
forest from the metaphors.
To be informed does
not necessarily mean
to have enough information,
but to be given clues.
Clues for reading a state
of affairs that makes sense,
or seem to make sense and makes
your life more meaningful or seem
to make your life more
meaningful meaning is
in the eye of the beholder.
When I, as a child growing
up in a dictatorship everything
had a political meaning.
Books could sell ten times
more copies than today
for the underlying meaning.
This has disappeared for decades,
perhaps it's coming back now
but for a long time politics was not
that interesting for
a general audience.
Though a few months ago I read some
stats that I did not double check,
but apparently Breitbart
had more hits than Pornhub,
which means that with successful
marketing politics could reach
out for more people
than we expected.
We should really stop this.
Censorship can also be
a source of success.
Back in the day when I was a
young poet one oven guard magazine
published a few of my teenage works.
The issue had a strange
cover that became a scandal.
It had a caricature of the Hungarian
court of arms going back more
than 1,000 years, but instead of
the two angels holding the shield,
they portrayed two horny
devils masturbating.
This has of course, freaked
out a few conservative members
of the parliament and the leader
of the farmers party was waving the
magazine in front of the parliament
in live coverage asking for the
copies to be smashed immediately.
But because of the scandal
and the free advertisement,
they sold five times
more copies than ever
and a lot more people
could read my poems.
Moving on.
Not only dictatorship
have great audiences,
but dictatorships are not
necessarily bad for literature.
Bad for the individual, but not
bad for the quality of the art.
In fact, most great works
of literature that we know
of were written in
some form of tyranny.
Since democratic governments
are pretty new,
in fact Greek democracy only
happened in a few cities
for a short period of time
and it was widely regarded
as a bad idea for a long time.
But every coin has two sides.
Kierkegaard also wrote the
tyrant dies and his rule is over,
the martyr dies and his rule begins.
Phalaris apparently was overthrown
by his people and tortured to death
in his favorite musical instrument
so his slaves could all hear his
swan song from the brazen bull,
play things with the
Gods, very Greek idea.
It's everywhere in Plato and
the Greek tragedies and in spite
of what you may have heard
in history class more
overwhelming majority
of the Greek population lived
in some sort of tyranny.
Now in a good old 20th century
dictatorship history is cut off
from the past and people are forced
into living in an eternal present.
My country was cut off from
the network that it used
to be part of for a millennia.
The two sides of the coin, the
20th century were either the fake
enthusiasm of totalitarian
regimes like Stalinism and fascism
and pretending that everything
is happening right now,
like never before, or
the version I grew up in
where you had the impression
that nothing is happening
and nothing is ever going to change.
When I was a kid most people
including the most educated
seriously believed that the division
of Cold War Europe and the rest
of the world will remain
like that forever.
I was one who didn't.
I studied history and I
learned that things change.
I thought the Wall will come
down some day and I wanted
to see it before that happens.
So, I went to all the nearby
countries in the former Soviet block
to see the end and participate in
the protest that changed the system.
I saw the euphoria.
The moment when people all of
a sudden started to believe
that finally they can take
their lives in their own hands.
It was a carnival in many cities,
especially in Berlin,
Prague and Belgrade.
Here's a paragraph from my book.
In Belgrade, time is
measured in faces.
After a week I began to
recognize people in the crowd.
In a years' time I would
recognize everyone.
Anyone who has a face also has time.
Watches are worn as ornaments, the
hands enclosing an arbitrary angle
that matches the wearer's mood.
It's not possible for me to be
late if I stay on the street.
The time for the demonstration
can be read from the faces.
You look at someone and
you know: it's time.
Neither of you will get
there on the agreed time,
but you meet somewhere else
where you wouldn't have met
if you had gone to where
you were supposed to meet.
Belgrade had escaped side real time.
People look one another in the eye.
They are whirling
on the merry-go-round
in a shower of confetti.
A chain reaction of faces
in a triggered explosion.
Belgrade faces are
incendiary, quick to flare up.
It is impossible to
become invisible.
The Belgrade are not faceless.
Out of any two faces,
one is always you.
The way we look at time is deeply
rooted in our habits and lifestyle.
We observe changes
and we call it time.
We had very different
observation behind the Iron Curtain
and what behind means
is already a viewpoint.
You were behind from
our perspective.
This could be a source of
many thought experiments.
Just take Vietnam for example; it
took me decades of my adult years
to realize that if you have lost
Vietnam, then they must have won.
Then who are we?
Then of course nobody
really looked at it that way
and you don't see many blockbusters
from the Vietcong perspective
either.
If they were to do
it, they should start
by imagining how time was
passing in those rabbit holes.
Can we step out of our box and think
of time beyond our own experience,
are we always going to be late.
Timelessness smartly is also
based on your experiences.
So your timelessness and my
timelessness may never sit
at the same table or the
same universe for one.
Timelessness seems to be a state and
you have all the time in the world,
which does not make sense, if
you consider time as rhythm.
Experiencing time can
also add to our sensation
in seeing another country or another
continent is profoundly alien.
When I was 13 years old my
parents drove me and my brother
to Western Europe one
summer holiday.
We had never been to
the West before,
passing Austria, we
didn't even blink.
It didn't feel that much different.
But when we arrived to Germany we
saw American soldiers with tattoos
and big motor bikes just like
in an Oliver Stone movie.
I'm not kidding, we got genuinely
scared and we wanted to go home.
The west felt cold and cruel.
We wanted to go back to our safe
little communist dictatorship.
Luckily my dad didn't approve.
On the two sides of the Iron Curtain
people had very different views
in time.
In America it seems nobody has time.
Everybody is busy.
You buy your time.
We had a completely different idea.
We had a lot of time on our hands.
You could learn Japanese or
Swahili, higher math or whatever.
You had time, but you did not have
things as opposed to the other side
that had a lot of things to
play with but no time to do so.
Behind the Iron Curtain you could
visit your friends at 2:00 a.m.,
no problem, just knock on the door.
You did not have to call,
anyway few people had phones.
And the reason for this was
that you're equally unimportant.
When you are unimportant you
have all the time in the world.
The idea of a job behind the Iron
Curtain was that you were there
with the intention of getting
nothing done, which is both cruel
and bad work could be a problem,
when nothing becomes nothing.
It's safe.
And not being safe in a
dictatorship can be quite different
from what may scare
you in these parts.
When I traveled more and I saw that
in the west everybody is so busy,
even the cleaning lady is busy
for weeks ahead you kind of have
to make an appointment you're your
children if you wanted to see them.
It was culture shock, but
it was really about time.
You may call it culture or jet lag.
If you ever had children you know
that time changes around a baby.
As if you have entered
a different time zone.
You don't know how long at
night or a day is to a child,
Joan Berger argues in Fortunate Man.
It may be that subjectively
a childhood is much longer
than the rest of a lifetime.
There is no dedicated sensory
organ that detects time,
it again might suggest
that the passing
of time is a psychological
phenomenon.
Time ticks fast or slow depending
on their age, emotional state,
whether we are in pain or
in love, or just bored.
As a child we learn time by playing.
Just like lion cubs learn to
kill, we learn to kill time.
How we deal with time
reflects on us.
In New York we are watching
the ball drop on Time Square,
counting backwards and forwards.
The idea of living in the past or
in the future, but unable to live
in the moment, unable to
exist without references,
without measuring or time constantly
but also measuring our
importance in comparison to others.
That's what we do waiting
for a moment.
And by waiting together
it feels more real.
We're afraid to miss it.
We're afraid of falling out
of time, of not existing,
of not having a life, so we try to
prove our existence by being busy.
Facebook is a perfect way
to avoid the presence,
by being constantly present.
A perfect distraction
with a measure of likes.
Another aspect I should
perhaps mention here,
still talking about the
point of view is the role
of humor in a dictatorship.
We watch television and
we saw very serious,
very boring people telling lies.
Then we went on to the pub and
then we heard jokes that were true.
You could only tell
the truth as a joke,
otherwise you could get arrested.
I still do not trust people who
are always serious, they lie.
A lack of movement seems to be
pretty absurd if you're able to look
at it from a distance,
absurdity was a daily bread
of the communist regime.
Absurd humor thrive behind
the Iron Curtain together
with absurd theater.
When life is absurd normality can
seem unnatural even revolutionary.
The riot police breaking
through the fog come marching
down the embankment, the static
perhaps too blatant but authentic.
Some people start to run but most
stand transfixed as if they're
at the shooting of a costume drama.
In the scene many men in armor
are marching in formation,
the clanking of the shields and the
thud of the boots parting in an air
of heightened solemnity
to the troop.
The movements are not robot-like
but loose after having to stand
around helplessly for so long,
they feel a sense of liberation.
They're fired by the will to fight.
They approach with steps
neither hasting or leisurely
but rather homely like someone
going out to check the mail
who knows full well
that it won't run away,
a steaming hot breakfast
is waiting for him.
It's just gone out for a moment,
accept has spotted something
in the grass, some large object, a
forgotten bowl or pair of sunglasses
and he proceeds to kick it
to the side with his leg.
In the Communist dictatorship
nobody is important individually
and money is not worth much so you
can only create value by sacrifice.
Human sacrifice is
crucial to the regime.
What's wrong with a little
human sacrifice compared
to eternity dictators would say.
In a university in which
everything is laid out eternally
and unchanging, innovation
is impossible.
Time is an illusion according
to the ancient Greek
Philosopher Parmenides.
And a deeper reality is
eternal and unchanging.
Now he has departed from this
strange world a little ahead
of me, that signifies nothing.
For us, believing physicist the
distinction between past, present
and future is only a
stubbornly, persistent illusion.
Albert Einstein wrote this a
month before his own death,
about the death of his
lifelong friend Michele Besso.
For Einstein the past and
the future exist eternally,
time does not flow, it just is.
In fact, all physical theory so
far devised, Etonian mechanics,
Einstein's two theories
of relativity,
even quantum mechanics
are time symmetric.
No era of time is indicated.
There is no physical reasons
why a smashed plate might not
rejoin itself.
This is hard science, not fiction,
or gene sequences are 95%
identical to those of yeast.
The difference between yeast
and the human being is largely
a matter of organization.
We share 50% of our
genetic code with a banana.
The same goes for a book, content
is one thing, but it's a matter
of how you organize your material.
Please do not understand
me too quickly.
Andrew Sjeed (ph) wrote, There
is a reason why we think slowly.
To also think fast,
they do not think.
They are hoarding information.
Your scientists have discovered
that the brains of people
with high IQ's tend to
be highly integrated
in neuropath connecting
distant brain regions.
Why less intelligent people's brain
build simpler, shorter routes.
But no one knows why some brains
construct much longer range
connections than others.
Perhaps it has to do with the
bigger picture or a bigger illusion.
I guess it's time for
a little Kafka.
I'm going to give you
three quick quotes;
the meaning of life
is that it stops.
I am free and that is why I'm lost.
I am a cage in search of a bird.
Reading Kafka time and space seems
to be very different
from your own world.
It can never get from A to B, and
it's hard to tell whether it's
because of temporal
or spatial relations.
Another quote, the first
sign of the beginning
of understanding is the wish to die.
That's kind of the
definition of time according
to Kafka in my interpretation.
There is an infinite amount of hope
in this universe, but not for us
and that's the definition of space.
I would like to point out
if needed that this humor
and if it doesn't sound funny,
you still have a lot of time.
We are dying, that's what
we do and we need a sense
of humor for the journey.
So let's talk about death and time.
There are two kinds of
literature in this respect.
Here it is hard to refrain from
the joke that there are two kinds
of people in the world, those
how say that there are two kinds
of people in the world and
those who say there aren't.
So there are two kinds
of literature.
One that says "I'm going to die".
It's a scream but all we hear is
just beautiful music of course,
that's the domain of poetry.
And the other kind says
"Hey we are all going
to die" this could be a novel
going on for 1,000 pages or a play
by Shakespeare where you have all
the characters laid out in the end.
With every work of art we create
a specific form of time for
or against death depending
on your disposition.
But before it starts to get
way too serious here's a bit
for comic relief.
The time is measured by death, in
this case not necessarily your own.
For those who may not know the
names in the next paragraph,
they're all communist
dictators and bad, bad people.
My bumpy road to sexual
maturity was paved
with the death of communist
dictators.
My first sexual experience coincided
with the death of [Inaudible].
I was bitten by a girl called
Diana in nursery school.
My voice broke when Tito died and
I first came and Brezhnev went.
For three days there was nothing
but classical music on the radio,
which I thought was over doing
it; some schools even closed.
Then for a long time, nothing.
As an experiment I took
a girl to the movies,
but the film was too good
and I got cramps in my hand.
Events accelerated in high school.
It was only a couple of
months between the first kiss
and the first frantic
fumbling following Andropov,
Cherenkov also checked out.
A couple more weeks and
it was [Inaudible] turn,
but I'd rather not go into that.
I first found out about the G spot
when [Inaudible] was executed.
[Inaudible] cast new light
on my broadening horizons,
luckily the charges were dropped.
Fidel, this I wrote
a long time before.
Still waiting.
Our expectations define time, more
than the orbit of suns and planets.
If you can look death
right in the eye,
if you have no trouble going
gently into the good night,
if you take away the
fear and horror of death,
what would you write about?
What would you do if you had
all the time in the world?
What would even the word "do" mean?
Time for a little [Inaudible].
The devil appears in
Ivan Karamazov (ph)
in an old fashioned clothe wearing
a huge golden ring and no watch.
For the devil time is relative
or at least not measured
in an earthly manner.
In the theory of relativity
time is not independent
of space, but united with it.
Einstein was reported to have
remarked that he learned more
from Dostoyevsky than
from other scientists.
Dostoyevsky work is a
quest for a cosmic order
that would not ignore the
sufferings of individuals.
But Einstein attempts to
find harmony in the universe
on the large scale that would not
ignore action on the nano level.
He was known for his fierce
resistance to new theories
and quantum mechanics
that would imply
that microscopic processes
are random.
Einstein's famous remark "God
does not play, dies" is an analogy
to Ivan Karmoslov's rejection to
any harmony built onto the suffering
of a child, for this
would imply that God plays
with the fates of individuals.
And that would be as mentioned
earlier a very Greek idea indeed.
Dostoyevsky's clock was ticking
in a more Judao Christian manner.
Ivan also complains to Iesha that
his mind is too three dimensional.
And he would need to think 4-D
to understand divine harmony.
He's too down to earth and does
not get time even in his dream;
the devil wears no watch,
that kind of a 3D guy,
talking about revolution
or space time.
And another quote, who has said
to have been both a chronophiliac,
a lover of time and a
chronophobiac someone who dreads
to loss of things and time.
Perhaps a good angle on this
is that he was a lepidopterist,
a butterfly collector who collects
miniature monuments of death.
The main character in Adda, his most
complex novel claims I confess I do
not believe in time.
And then goes on about the
highest enjoyment of timelessness
and ecstasy and behind the ecstasy a
sense of oneness with sun and stone.
A thrill of gratitude
to whom it may concern.
Navaco's hero negates the future
and so does proofs by the way
and embraces the past
which equates with death
and conceive eternity
as a work of art.
Space is comedy, time is tragedy.
And the suspicious hyphen
between them, no he does not
like the idea of space time.
That would be of course
tragic comedy.
In Adda, the core of the book,
the texture of time is
revealed by the intervals.
Nothing prevents mankind as such
from having no future at all.
Either by evolving
into a novo [Inaudible]
which will enjoy other
variety of being and dreaming,
beyond man's notion of time, or by
evolving into a sub-human slime.
I wish to caress time.
I delight essentially in time and
its stuff and spread in the fall
of its folds, in the very
palpability of its [Inaudible].
Time is written, in
[Inaudible] of warm, humid night.
Brain ripple, breathing,
the drum in my temple,
these are faithful time keepers.
And reason corrects
the feverish beat.
Maybe the only thing that hints
at a sense of time is written,
the great gap between the black
beats, the tender interval,
the regular throb itself merely
brings back the miserable idea
of measurement.
But in between something
like two time lurks.
If my eye tells me
something about space,
my ear tells me something
about time.
I can listen to time
only between stresses.
Listening not to time itself
but to the [Inaudible] coursing
through my brain, space
is the imposter.
Some critiques may say
that this is pseudo-science
and pseudo philosophy, but
there's also poetry and science.
[Inaudible] came up with a
theory of cosmology selection
to explain the universe
not going in -
to explain how the
universe got going in time.
He reconceived the universe as
if it were some kind of organism.
Everything in the universe
is evolving at every scaling
to novelty according to Smolling.
He believes at the quantum
level the deeper reality is time
and not space.
I think it likely that space
would turn out to be an illusion,
Smolling remarks, a way to
organize our impressions of things
on a large scale, but only
a rough and emergent way
to see the world as a whole.
And now back to Kafka who
writes, by believing passionately
in something we create it.
The non-existence is whatever we
have not sufficiently desired,
so lack of existence
is lack of desire.
There's a dream equality to the
trial, the court itself is not real,
but reactions to the court are real.
The dreams are more or less real
than our daily life depends
on the level of desire.
Kafka had dreamt the world that
we call real today and we have
to face it on a daily basis.
If you visit the Kafka museum
in Prague you will find
that the shop is bigger
than the rest of the place.
There is Kafka on everything.
You can even buy Kafka
underwear and if you know
that the very image had already
been doctored by his publisher back
in the day you may say
it's rather Kafka-esque.
Today we even call Kafka-esque
stuff that was written before Kafka.
Reality is imprecise said the
physicist Werner Heisenberg,
which is rather Kafka-esque
coming from an [Inaudible] who was
in charge of Nazi atomic
bomb project.
According to Kierkegaard
the truth is a trap,
you cannot get it without
it getting you.
Newsbore once said that quantum
mechanics only makes sense
if you change the meaning
of the word understand.
>> Peter Zilahy: Einstein
said that the problem
of the now were seriously.
He explained that the experience
of the now means nothing
special for man.
Something essentially different
from the past and the future
but that this important
difference does not
and cannot occur within physics.
That this experience cannot
be grasped by science seen
to him a matter of painful,
but inevitable regret.
Physical theories do
not privilege now.
Physics tells us that
everything that will ever happen
in the universe has
already happened.
Dostoyevsky writes
[Inaudible] last night
in which each moment
stretches into eternity.
And now one paragraph, and I know -
I was a virgin but
it didn't bother me.
I didn't have a clue.
The world was black and white.
You could watch it on TV.
It's still in front of me, extra
time in the whole Argentina final,
the link up of the bother
[Inaudible] the death of the king.
I didn't know who Elvis was,
but my dad was [Inaudible]
The gas explosion
in [Inaudible] the volcanic
clouds over Mt. St. Helen's,
the Hungarians space flight
and the Rubik Cube world
championship in Budapest.
Sports were exciting
in black and white.
During a boxing match you
had to count the number
of strips on the guys socks.
I even remember how many
strips my first date had,
not sure about the
color of the eyes.
I see her in black and white.
After the first kiss my parents
bought a colored TV and it turned
out that the Dutch are
orange, the Italians are blue
and there are green and red devils.
Only the Germans remain
black and white
as if they were being punished.
The country was split into two as
well, almost felt sorry for them.
What we think and what we know
about the universe has changed
through centuries and change
the same way in the future.
Today people believe in space ship
and that's what they
expect appearing in the sky,
and not Zeus appearing as an eagle.
Science has historically
taken the physical world to be
out there separate from
us and it's not surprising
that it has not succeeded
in describing consciousness.
The outside world cannot
be separated
from the experience we have of it.
Consciousness appears to be a
construction like virtual reality.
It's an illusion but
no less real for that.
There is still a real world
but the two natures
hidden behind the illusion,
what we call real is the
illusion we most believe in.
Ludwig Wittgenstein while he
was a professor at Cambridge
at Trinity College
once wondered in front
of his students why do people say it
was natural to say the sun revolved
around the earth, for
which one student answered,
"Because it looked like that".
To which Wittgenstein
replies, "And how would it look
if it was the other way around"?
All right.
I can cut it short, do
we have five minutes?
Okay, I do a little more reading.
When my grandfather
was the same age as me,
[Inaudible] showed
the heir apparent,
fait brought the failed student
and the future emperor together.
The meeting brought
immortality to both and death,
they did not know each other
and possibly they exchanged
a look, how do you do.
The princette and the prince,
the prince and the pauper.
One thing is certain they
both heard the shots.
Since then in the depths
of parks [Inaudible] prince
of statues are shooting are
France Ferdinand statues.
The trench warfare of
[Inaudible] Prince of Streets
with France Ferdinand avenues.
You can't battle over memorial
plaques, museums, medals, films,
in Sarajevo they took down the
statue of the crown prince,
his death which gave
millions a cause to die
for was the crowning
achievement of his life.
The first world war began as a feud.
When my grandfather
was the same age as me,
his fate crossed that of another.
Both men were called
up as volunteers
into the imperial and royal army.
Both were sent to the southern front
and during the Russian
offensive, both to Galicia.
Both distinguished
themselves, [Inaudible]
and his company captured an 18
member strong Russian union,
while during a surprise attack
my grandfather received 21 shell
fragments and a bunch of medals.
When they wanted to amputate his
leg he pulled a gun on the surgeon
and ordered him out
of the operating room.
Within a year they were both taken
prisoner and both loss consciousness
in the middle of hand
to hand combat.
They wake up in hospital
and in their fevers they both
haunted by an earlier trauma.
My grandfather thinks they
want to amputate his leg,
while JB accuses the saint
hanging above his bed
of trying to steal his clothes.
After several failed
attempts of fleeing,
the revolution catches
up with them in Russia.
[Inaudible] is caught by the
Bolsheviks and is enlisted
in the international brigade.
While lying next to his Russian wife
he suddenly realizes the meaning
of historical inevitability.
I hate to think what might have
happened had my grandfather ended
up in the hands of the Bolsheviks.
In the hospital where they're lives
ended before the century had come
to an end.
The century in which
everything was stood on its head.
Tito's leg is amputated and somebody
steals my grandfather's clothes.
The little differences are crucial
as in our everyday
moves, as in genocide.
Kane and Abel, Serbs and
Croats, Shiites and [Inaudible],
the more similar you are the
more you look at the differences.
What bothers us is the
similarity without union.
Our main problem is not
that we are too different,
but that we are too similar.
We are all limited similarly.
It is our limitations
that connects us,
and what connects us
also separates us.
So going back to the banana,
it is all about how we
organize our limitations.
In politics and science
and in the arts as well.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Peter Zilahy: Just before the
Q & A I would like to mention
that there's a - apart from
the million quotes that I used
in this book, I also used a very
nice book of a friend of mind
for the science parts, Christopher
Potter, How to Make a Human Being;
I just wanted to make
this acknowledgement.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.